Hi everyone it's Jerry. On November 24th, 2012
Magnus Carlsen competed in a game against
the world in the 2nd Gran chess festival held
in Mexico City, Mexico. For each of the moves
the world voted for one of three options that
were selected by grandmaster players. And
in this game Carlsen, on the white end, kicked
off with e4. And what was voted on was the
Sicilian c5. After knight f3 d6 were heading
for an open Sicilian with d4. cxd Nxd knight
f6, knight c3 and now a6 indicating the Najdorf
and on move six h3. What's also quite popular
is bishop e3 and after e5 the knight will
make use of that b3 square. However with h3,
white is intending on g4 bishop g2 ideas and
a rerouting of this knight to this f5 square.
So that's exactly what we have. After e5 it's
not the knight going to b3 but rather e2.
Bishop e7, g4 expanding, you'll note that this
is a strong support point on f5. This knight is
on its way there. Black castles, knight g3
black gets some development in connecting
their knights and after knight f5 is now in
a position to just move this knight out of
the way and it's quite timely. This d-pawn
is now defended and there's now pressure on
this e4 point. Bishop g2 development defense
of e4. More development on the black side
and now castles. After b5 we have a3. This
knight does not want to be kicked around and
so rook c8 half open file very logical moves
and now f4 striking at this center and has
the potential to enter the black territory.
After this knight moves this pawn could be
expanding and that's exactly what we would
have, white establishing a pawn in the black
position. So what follows is knight a4 which
is a curious move to see because you do run
the risk of...well a messy looking pawn structure.
But the idea here is to eliminate this knight
on c3 which is better placed than this knight
on c5(c6). Okay, you could reason this knight
is applying pressure to this pawn but there's
not really a way to put additional pressure
on e4 and if you recognize the weakest point
in the black position, the weakest square
d5, you really want to try and get rid of
a knight that could potentially make use of
it. So knight a4 addresses this idea and although
black has doubled a-pawns, it now allows black
to put pressure on this b-pawn. And well we're
not going to see this right away but the potential
to put pressure on the heart of this white
queen side structure is there. And if pressure
is placed on b2, it may prove to be quite
uncomfortable for white to complete their
queen side development. So first things first
we have some expansion, a lot of action actually
on the king side and a lot of structural changes
within these next few moves, and most of which
are are all forced. After g5 knight d7 knight
takes bishop, queen recaptures, and now f5
hitting that bishop, it only has one choice.
It reacts counterattacking move hitting the
rook and the rook just bumps up to f2. And
black has to be very careful right now because
the main idea is to just a rip open this king
side structure by making this pawn on g7 flinch,
or in other words trying to get in f6, which
is often recognized as a giant thorn in one's
position. So black does well to avoid this
by playing f6, and now we have g6. A lot of
tension going on with these last couple of
moves between the pawns, and the decision
here now by black is a great one. Because
there is the option of taking the pawn and
after the recapture, working with this particular
structure, or just playing h6. Now what was
decided on was h6 and we'll see how this now
turns out to be a great inconvenience to black
because this pawn is just priceless. Controlling
these two flight squares it will always present
black a problem for as long as there is one
heavy piece on the board. There's the potential
for back rank issues, and we'll see that highlighted
later on. But the other alternative...okay
what was played was h6. The other alternative
it to actually capture on g6, and at first
I thought that this would be a mistake because
what it now allows white to do, or so I thought,
what it now allows white to do is play queen
h5, and then make use of this h7 square. But
black, fortunately, would be in time to meet
that threat. After h takes g, what we could
have or what we should have is rook f to
d8 which is vacating f8 to meet a move such
as queen h5 with knight f8, and black is there
just in the nick of time to not only defend
h7 but the other idea is that it's putting
pressure on g6. And so things aren't now as
clean for white. That's not to say that this
is the best continuation, but just to highlight
how black would be defending should queen
h5 be played: the knight would make use of
f8, defend against h7, and apply pressure
to this pawn which runs the risk of just falling.
Not long off, we could be seeing this queen
e8 move and white is having to find some accurate
moves to be defending against this, and in
the meantime there could still be mounting
pressure against the white queen side. So,
we didn't have this but this is a great turning
point in the game and that will often spring
about when we have structural changes. So
h6 was played. There is no potential now to
get to that h7 square with the queen. So things
now transition since the king side is locked.
We're now transitioning to the queen side.
So bishop e3 is played just completing...
getting more pieces involved. And the
other idea that white maybe could have gone
with is b3. Taking note that all of these
squares are just taken away from that light-squared
bishop. And so the bishop will be kicked off
of it after either an immediate capture, or
just going back right away. Let's say takes
takes the bishop kind of gets kicked around
for a bunch of moves here. a4 bishop c6, and
after b4 white will not be denied of getting
to this nice diagonal and development is really
really smooth. If let's say king h8, in anticipation
of a queen playing to b3, we just have really
smooth development. And the big thing here
is that this pawn here is still a liability,
and these pawns are perfectly healthy and
soon enough can be converted into a passed
pawn. So that was another route white could
have gone for as soon as h6 was played...
to play b3, but we didn't have that. Instead
it was bishop e3, knight c5 repositioning.
Rook d2, it only came there to meet that bishop
threat when it played to that c4 square. So
now it's functioning very well placing pressure
on d6, that rooks gets involved to defend.
Queen e1 so that these rooks can now double.
Queen b7. And I was talking earlier about
the rook maybe putting pressure on b2, but
sure enough we can also have that queen playing
the role. White avoids this not wanting to
play a very passive move. Rook b1 is just
not the way to go. It could always be let's
say kicked away. There's not a convenient
way to defend against b2, so the idea here
is to put pressure on c6. And the big thing
here is really all about activity. Queen takes
b2 was played in other words because trying
to hang on to let's say this pawn on d6 just
runs into some trouble. I mean black is on
the defensive in a great way. What do you
do after something like queen to f2, putting
more pressure on the knight, with still ideas
of penetrating into this back rank of black's?
It's very very difficult. Keep in mind that
a move such as knight takes e is not available
because of queen f3. What do you do about
this pin? There's not a good solution. If
d5, you can actually just take this knight.
Again, taking advantage of this back rank.
This would be the best choice for black at
that point, to immediately play the queen
back e8. But after the smoke clears, white
is clearly just up a minor piece. So, we wouldn't
have knight takes e at this point. The main
idea again is not to just go and resort to
a completely defensive position. I guess you
could play queen c6 after queen f2, the knight
going backwards just to defend the pawn, but
that's not really the way to play the game.
So instead opting for activity, grabbing on
b2, and is just a step away from grabbing
a3 and this pawn becomes passed. But there
is some serious issues again, all really attributed
to this pawn being so deep in the black position,
controlling these flight squares. So, rook
takes d, rook takes d, rook takes d, and now
queen to a3. This pawn is passed and this
queen is indirectly observing that rook on
d6. Queen d2, renewing this idea of getting to
the back rank. Knight d3, an interference
move. There's a disconnect now between the
queen and the rook. The queen is hitting the
rook. And we have rook d7, probably the most
active square for that rook right now. Bishop
b5 hits the rook. Rook d5, and now knight
to f4 hitting this rook. Rook c5 is a cute
move just interfering. Black just a moment
ago played that knight to d3 move interfering
with the queen and rook's connection. And we
have a similar thing going on right now...
the rook is getting in the way of the queen
coming back to maybe defend along this diagonal.
And of course if rook takes, we're just going
to have this mate. Once again everything is
highlighted as soon as one of the pieces is
no longer around to watch over that eighth
rank, white can simply exploit it. So, after
rook c5 we have rook e8. And there are alternatives
here... there's many different choices for
the rook, but with each of them white is always
slightly better, if not winning There's maybe
some more resistance that could be put up,
but what was chosen on this move thirty was
rook to e8, and now this is really going to
crumble very fast. What white could have played,
what Magnus could've played is an immediate
c4, knowing that if let's say the bishop plays
to d7, white can actually go ahead and grab
it. And allow a very appealing looking queen
takes bishop with check, giving a fork to
the king and rook. That can just be met with
king h2, and there's no time to take the rook
because we would just have check followed
by mate in one. So, there is just a little
bit of a long winded variation here. After
king h2, there's not much you can do about
the rook being threatened. And also this idea
of bringing the rook to maybe c7 or c8. If
rook f8 is tried, rook c8. What to do about
taking the rook and giving mate here or, just
giving check first and then taking the rook?
There's not much you can do. Knight g6, pawn
takes knight. There's just a couple checks
that could be thrown in here and eventually
the king is going to find a safe haven on
this h5 square, and this idea of the back
rank is still present. So what we do have
instead of this c4 move immediately, this
is what could have been played successfully,
but there is a certain degree of calculation
involved knowing that you can avoid let's
say that perpetual check. Instead of c4, we
do have rook to c7, getting back on that seventh
rank. Queen gives check, king h2, and now
king to h8. There's not much that black can
do right here. There's the idea with king
h8 is just to get off of this diagonal so
that it, you know, when the queen... if the
queen does land on that diagonal, it's not
going to come with check. If for example,
instead of the king going in the corner, if
we had the pawn just trying to promote...
well we snip the knight, pawn takes bishop,
queen gives check, king in the corner, queen
f7. What do you do about the pressure on g7?
Not much to do. Rook g8, you just take the
rook, and then you deliver mate in two. So,
one other variation might be, after this position,
after king h2 excuse me, queen a2, preventing
let's say c2 from coming about...
we could have queen to d6. That's not to say
that this is the best move in this position,
but just to highlight the strength of this
pawn right here on g6. It's not just around
to provide mate on the back rank, but there
are tactics involved against the g7 point
as well. If for example a3 just trying again
to promote, this is the tactic that we would
have: rook takes g, king takes g, queen c7,
king back, the queen gives check. And now
this bishop starts to play a role. And this
will be leading to mate in a couple. So, however
you slice it, after queen a1, for sure, black
is completely busted. So, queen a1, king h2,
the king gets off of this diagonal. And what
follows is c4. This bishop is killed. And,
what black tries is just to advance the pawn.
There's not much more that could be done.
So Magnus grabs that bishop, queen b2, pawn
grabs on a6 and well this guy is just a couple
steps away and there's just nothing to do
for black at this point. What is tried is
queen takes queen, bishop takes queen, knight
e2. And after a calm rook c4, a2 and rook
to a4, this pawn is lost, this pawn remains
passed, and white is still up a piece. Black
is dead. And at this point the world ends
up resigning to the world's number one, Magnus
Carlsen. So, that's all for this video. As
always, I hope you got something out of it.
Take care, bye.